Welcome to the front-end
web developer Nanodegree.
I'm Mike Wales, the director for
this Nanodegree program.
And I'm Cameron Pittman.
I'm a Senior Content Developer
here at Udacity.
Along with a few other folks, Mike and
I are here to help you become
a front-end web developer.
In fact you are already
on your Your way.
>> That's right.
>> From this point forward,
we want you to call yourself
a front end web developer.
Congratulations, tell your friends.
>> I think it makes sense to not just
give you an idea of where you are in
the web development world but
when you are.
>> Like a history lesson?
>> Well yeah.
Mike, you know this better than anybody
else, the web's been around for a while.
You've been doing this since what, 92?
>> Pretty much, although, back then
technically it wasn't called the web.
But yeah.
Early 90s [INAUDIBLE] I remember AOL and
dial up modems.
Funny thing is technology has
changed quite a bit since then.
But the technology
behind browsers has not.
In fact today's modern web browser
still support the same technology that
the original Netscape Navigator
had back in 1994.
>> That's right.
You were joining a crazy world.
One that simultaneously
stays the same yet changes.
In fact is changing faster
today than it ever has before.
Let's see how.